[Music]
the career of musician Chris Neely has
been marked by the unexpected and by
frequent bouts of reinvention he's
performed with nickel creek a group he
formed when he was just a child
and later the Punch Brothers he's also
had a solo career including
collaborations with artists as varied as
bela Fleck and yo-yo ma and now a whole
new career turn he's in his first season
as the new host of Public Radio's a
Prairie Home Companion he'll perform in
a moment but first I spoke with him
about his new role you've lost a lot of
weight I'm kind of worried about you or
something how you doing I am feeling
fantastic
when Garrison Keillor chose Christie Lee
to succeed him as host of A Prairie Home
Companion it was a surprise to almost
everyone especially the 35 year old
musician did you have any idea this was
coming oh absolutely not
yeah out of the clear blue sky he starts
outlining this plan I think I think I'm
gonna leave the radio pretty soon um I
think maybe you should do it after and
what was your first reaction to the idea
when he says the words my mind just
exploded with all the things I want to
do show like just oh I could do this
like this I could call this person as
host feely has brought in an all-star
cast of musical friends Marcus Mumford
joined him on last week's broadcast
Steve Martin will join him tonight a
virtuoso on the mandolin fili has been
playing since he was five when he begged
his parents for the instrument was it
the sound of the mandolin the sound of
it I love if you just think about a
mandolin sound in your head even that
classic like Lady and the [ __ ] you know
it's just very precise ah nice edge kind
of a sound and I think I really I loved
that as a little little boy and
continued to love what it demands of a
player in terms of precision he was just
eight when he formed the band nickel
creek with his California friends Sarah
and Shaw
Watkins their major label debut album in
2000 went platinum and the follow-up won
them a Grammy for Best folk album fili
who grew up listening to a Prairie Home
Companion first appeared on the
broadcast in 1996 at age 15 what do you
remember about it I remember everything
about dad I remember I remember walking
to the department store on the way there
to get a nice shirt
because I didn't have one he would
perform on the show 24 times before
becoming its host what about the
intimidation factor of succeeding
Garrison Keillor my perception of other
people's perception of this handoff is
that there's no way it could work but
somehow you liked the challenge of that
but think about it the pressures off
haha like it's because you're a failure
already well no just because no one
thinks it can happen yes and and so if
it can that'll be a hell of a good
surprise